well I'm both hopeful and pessimistic
and I'm pessimistic when i watch
television or watch a lot of the the
stuff that reflects culture because I do
see a deterioration of some of the
values that I think Americans have been
known for but I also see a resurgence of
hope in that I see churches coming to
the table and saying it's not enough for
us to just talk about the souls of
people we also need to talk about their
bodies when I see churches that are
coming to the table and saying let's not
just talk about people salvation but
let's talk about the fact that the
people that we're trying to bring
salvation to also are hungry aren't
wearing any clothes they don't have a
way to make a living they're sick they
have HIV they don't access to good water
they don't have access to good health
care when I see the marriage of those
two ideas together caring for the body
and the soul and a lot of churches
realizing that's our responsibility to
me that gives me a lot of hope it seems
like that people are less interested I
think they're more interested in
spiritual things I think there are a lot
of people that would call themselves
spiritual but that could include all
different types of viewpoints that's not
the same as saying people are in
relationship with God so I think they're
becoming less religious and maybe more
spiritual and I don't necessarily see
that as a good thing
you